hello freak bitches this stink yeah the
bathroom smells so bad the bathroom
smells so bad from pollution I think
which is polluted water just polluted
water makes a smell man and also they
don't they don't want you can say it
died thinking about it there's no toilet
it's just all the porcelain hole the
shine wha yeah you have to squat it's a
squat suppose that's better few miles
supposedly supposedly I was in the
Forbidden City I was walking around
there the Emperor's Palace yeah and I
got bad diarrhea it was bad like
sweating like I got a fuck and then
there's a picture toilet you go in there
and you fucking run and smells soon as
you cross the threshold or the
background smells horrible and you open
up the first toy the stall door and your
mind can't even register at first like
this must be under construction this
book cuz there's no toilet here so
that's the only explanation and then you
go to the next one and you're like what
Oh zip a block no there's no paper what
yeah well first I just said I'm not
doing this I'm not done walked away oh
my god I was like I was like two steps
out of the bathroom oh yeah diarrhea
what do you mean I'm not doing it of
course I'm doing it so you went back in
and washed your butt you have to do so
they so this guy who owned the cone the
bar the club was it in Shanghai gave me
this these tissue packet and he goes
you'll need it I thought it's for
pollution and he goes you'll need this
and I hit and I just had it yeah and
then it was like oh yeah
you got to pull your pants all the way
down squat over it but also trying to
shit into your pants oh you can't go
over the balls of your feet oh no
there's probably a better way what do
you do with the explosive diarrhea
though it seems like you're gonna miss
last it into that hole you're you're
you're never over that hole like half a
foot over the hole is that good for your
quads it's good for your core I would
feel like that would really work your
core a lot and there's no air
conditioning it's
so hot that would work you're resolved
yeah that's why the Asians are thin
maybe it's not the low sugar diets is
the shit shit you're hit your ankle
explosive diarrhea feels like I'm just
gonna hit my picture this picture this
I'm down okay or easily squatting right
now so like you're your ass is right
it's over the hole yeah filling the hole
essentially feet if your moves are far
enough away what do you do if you have
bad knees how you do after that but I
sit like that all the time that's how
Asians just squat eat all the time I do
that sometimes really sits like that
yeah sure once in a while if we're back
in one of those toilets somebody dropped
their brand-new phone in the toilet and
so the husband went to go in there and
grab it ass down because of the fumes
and whoa-ho the woman tried to grab the
guy out because those few people died
three injured fine by me but they're all
perfect yeah we have a so good America
Dick Cheney's right they have those they
have those shitters on the train when
it's moving around and stuff they have
those jitters Dick Cheney's right eye
open unlike tissue Pandits what What did
he say
right can we do a douche bags definition
possible when you say douche bag there
I'm curious as to the what specifically
just dumb assholes okay just dumb
oh yeah a lot of assholes like you ever
go to Kim Kardashian's Instagram page
not a long time Louisa's go there and
just read some of the fucking comments
about children right into anything
anything that yawns just fucking hey I'm
sure I'm sure it's there it's diluted
YouTube it's because you're commenting
on a photo or video instead of like a
Twitter where you're just talking about
words
I honestly think anything worth anything
should be comments deleted comics
disabled because the the problem is like
they very rarely it's it's rare that you
it generates a really fascinating
conversation in the comments it's super
common that is just kunti shitheads it
depends on a subject matter like in my
case sometimes I do get relevant
discussion in the comments anything tech
discussion like
pretty respectful but you get this weird
fanboys and stuff that gets militant
surprisingly these are like yeah I don't
know I have this theory like you know
when you go to a coffee shop and you
look around yet Starbucks everyone has
their phones on the table you know you
notice that like yeah like it's in the
public space it's like it's like
representative of you in some way right
and I have this feeling that this is for
a lot of people this is a major
investment you know outside of their car
or whatever it's really close to you
it's in your pocket all the time and so
I think people are really concerned with
making the wrong decision you know
they're really concerned that their
thing is not the best and so in my case
what will happen is I'll put up a video
within you know they haven't even had
time to finish watching it and Apple
sucks or Android sucks or whatever and
really it's fear it's fear that you made
the wrong decision and so it well like
in many places in life you get angry
when you're afraid and so god forbid a
new product comes out that obsoletes
yours and you don't have the money to
replace it so you you take this position
of defending the other thing because
that's easier than justifying the cost
of the new one so I've actually there
were a couple of really cool articles on
fanboy ISM that I was interviewed for
and you know we went we went deep into
how you know how people sort of figure
that out but there's definitely this
undercurrent below the the tech space
the consumer product space where these
are becoming more and more like fashion
symbols like like you know
representative of your personality maybe
more so than at this then as a tool you
know less less of a hammer and more like
a piece of jewelry like a watch or some
isn't it also that people just love
being on teams whether it's team oh oh
public an teams led team most most
definitely and and I've done some rants
on this in the past like I I feel they
need to tell people like I'm a fan of
technology when I was coming up as a kid
like if anybody brought me any of this
stuff I would I would be super excited
horse and I'm cool with saying that you
know but but yeah there is there is
definitely a team aspect where people
they want to belong to something I say
belong to team technology if that's what
you're into because the truth is these
device
is in these platforms push one another
that the the positive things that happen
in Android push iOS to be better in the
positive things that happen in iOS push
Android to be better and the same thing
goes for laptops desktops really
anywhere there's innovation having a
little bit of competition is a positive
thing